[Music]
welcome back to cbs mornings it's 7 30.
tonight the 75th season of the nba kicks
off with the defending champion
milwaukee bucks hosting the brooklyn
nets but one star player will not be on
the court that would be the net's kyrie
irving of course because he refuses to
be vaccinated against covert 19 and the
team has decided that that means he
cannot play
nba legend magic johnson has been
outspoken about this issue and he's also
now a league ambassador for this
75th season he spoke to lily luciano in
los angeles where he was a player of
course lilia good morning to you
good morning tony this 75 year
anniversary is meant to be a celebration
of the success of the league which now
has 30 franchises each worth an
estimated 2.5 billion dollars with a b
in legend magic johnson has been a
global ambassador for the nba but also
for health i mean nobody understands the
importance of health advocacy like magic
who himself had to retire 30 years ago
after an hiv diagnosis but now he's
still on the world stage and with a new
role
this league is unbelievable has been
will be
i just want to thank god for letting me
be a part of it basketball legend magic
johnson is one of the nba's greatest
stars
whose on-the-court talent and
off-the-court charisma helped bring new
fans to the nba in the 1980s as one of
its first true celebrity superstars the
league is now calling on the five-time
nba champion again this time as an
ambassador for the nba's 75th
anniversary season i guess i've been an
ambassador unofficially
[Laughter]
certainly globally for 40-something
years anyway so so it's nice to have
this title and
to celebrate 75 years this will be one
of the most exciting seasons not just
because it's 75 years but because so
many teams really have a legitimate
chance to win
everybody gets to see
what the nba is really about which is
beautiful beautiful basketball i mean
awesome
the defending champions the milwaukee
bucks will officially open the season a
marquee matchup against kevin durant and
the brooklyn nets but hanging over the
season opener the absence of net
superstar kyrie irving who's refusing to
get vaccinated which bars him from
playing home games under new york's
coveted restrictions as a result nets
management required irving to sit out
until he gets the shot nba commissioner
adam silver said monday that while the
league itself has no vaccine mandate it
will respect local restrictions i hope
that kyrie sort of
despite
how strongly he feels about the
vaccination
ultimately decides to get vaccinated
because
i'd love to see him play basketball this
season silver says 96 percent of the
league is vaccinated but he wants every
single player to get the shot and so
does magic johnson do you think every
player should come out and say
i will get a vaccine i'm vaccinated and
so should you oh for sure you know
that's why i got my two shots and made
sure
i put it out on social media i wanted
especially my community to know that
first of all it's safe
and the players again people listen to
them they follow them that's very
important plus the last thing is this
you have said to your teammates i'm
going to be there for you
well you can't be there if you don't get
vaccinated
you're letting them down
and then that hurts our chances of
winning the championship i would never
do that to my teammates never
part of the league's 75-year anniversary
includes expanding its list of the 50
best players of all time to 75. of
course magic johnson is already on that
list but he says he's excited to know
which active players will make the cut
some of those names will be revealed
later tonight nate
one of the greatest of all times but
watching magic johnson taught me how to
play the point guard position lilia
thank you so much